at this software company
pay negotiations are conducted a little
differently
here it's your colleague that sets your
salary
because we trust and we show that
transparency that will be paid back
by more trust from the people in the
team in the company
and that will create a positive feedback
loop that will benefit everyone
buenos aires based 10 pines has an
open book management style that allows
employees
to have a say in all major decisions
including who they hire
and how much they're paid in the final
interview of the hiring process
the candidate meets the entire company
around 90 people
who in turn decide if they're a good fit
and then their starting salary
it's important that if this person a new
hire enters the company
then everyone will know that the salary
and will be
will accept and will acknowledge that
it's it looks at least with a small
information that we have from that
person it looks fair at that time
three times a year the company has a
rates meeting
in which employees can pitch and present
why they deserve a raise
before their teammates take a vote we
live in a market that it's competing all
the time for the talent
and of course one of the ways that it
competes by paying and raising salaries
all the time
so it's an important aspect that people
need to know if they are being paid a
first salary or not
ten pines calls this sociocracy and
although it may sound
unique its practices are grounded in a
larger trend
known as radical transparency right now
we're
in really fertile ground for this kind
of idea to sprout up and i think we're
going to see many many many things
kind of popping up all over the world
many many experiments over the next
couple of years in this approach
and so as companies and employees start
to look towards a post-pandemic
workplace
could honesty really be the best policy
[Music]
radical transparency is a concept that
broadly applied just means
being super transparent about details
that a company or an organization might
otherwise
choose to keep secret or keep hidden or
limited to a certain number
of executives or leaders at a company
netflix is one of the companies best
known for its culture of radical
transparency
that it says promotes accountability
netflix the company takes radical
transparency very far and they go so far
as to have
you know public discussions or public
emails sent out to
you know sometimes hundreds of employees
discussing why someone was fired
sometimes the discussions about why
someone is getting fired happen
right in front of them so that they have
a chance to share all the ways
that they made mistakes that led to them
no longer working at the company
but they also have policies that people
might see as pretty welcome so for
example
they allow their employees to
sort of at their discretion make use of
their expense accounts so that means
no one's really tracking their vacation
days or their expense spending
or or things that are you know useful to
this person getting their job done and
the idea is that
it's freedom and and sort of freedom and
responsibility
that is given to these employees so that
they have a chance
to do their job the best they can
without being micromanaged
but you only have to look at netflix on
glassdoor
to see that this approach isn't for
everyone
anytime you have a company culture
that's sort of extreme
you have the chance to attract people
for whom it's really a good fit
and you're also going to turn off a lot
of people who just feel that this isn't
for them and it may explain why this
isn't
a more widely adopted thing because it's
difficult and it requires someone at the
top
really committed to working through the
uncomfortable parts of it
in order to make it the company culture
for netflix that person at the top is
reed hastings
he believes the company's success stems
from its high performance
culture in the traditional industrial
paradigm
you know you have to do something wrong
to get let go
you can think of a job as sort of a
property right you know until you lose
it by abusing your position
but if you think about professional
sports you know if
that team is going to win a championship
it has to have a mix of the right
players that
work well together that are the absolute
best in the world
and so we try to model ourselves like a
professional sports team
so highly paid but you got to earn your
position every year
and it's about performance and you know
that's not
right for everybody some people care
mostly about job security
other people care mostly about excellent
colleagues
and you know playing great team ball
to achieving something important for the
consumers
and the netflix numbers seem to show
that radical transparency is working
while it fires people at a higher rate
than the average u.s
company people actually choose to leave
at a much
lower rate but you also don't hear about
the companies for which this didn't work
so well right or the companies that
might have gotten to mid-size and then
things sort of fizzled out
or you know we look at netflix and
bridgewater and we we see these success
stories but we're also not hearing
necessarily the stories where it was
hard to keep a company culture going as
it grew much bigger or it was hard to
keep it going as the company expanded
very quickly
but beyond company's success how does
this high accountability system
impact the average employee so from a
neuroscience perspective
um if we think about what the brain is
in innately
craving like the brain's own goals one
of them is
a sense of certainty like the ability to
predict
what's going to happen the next second
when you feel you know uncertain
it activates quite a strong threat
response in the brain which takes your
attention away
from what you're trying to focus on when
certainty goes
up you activate a reward network in the
brain and your
your field of view literally opens up
your perspective and
how much you can think about opens up
and your ability to be creative
so one of the things with radical
transparency is people have a lot more
certainty
about what's expected of them about what
great performance looks like in any
domain
about what other people are doing how
that compares to what they're doing so
it really increases your access to
information so you can feel a lot more
certain about everything that's going on
in your world
and this this drive for certainty is
such a fundamental part of the brain
it's literally one of the brain's
intrinsic goals and it's not just
an increased sense of certainty that can
help us do our jobs
when you give people access to
information about who's paid what and
how and what they're doing and how the
whole business works and
the whole infrastructure people feel a
much greater sense of control
they feel like they can make decisions
they feel like they
are able to to take actions and as a
result
improve their career or their
performance
[Music]
while a radical transparency model may
check out on a biological level
it definitely isn't a one-size-fits-all
solution as humans we have incredible
neural diversity
right there are people who thrive under
incredible pressure and in fact they're
really bored unless there's enormous
change and uncertainty going on and
and there are people who will fall apart
if
the subway schedule changes i i will say
that radical transparency as a concept
will suit a number of kinds of
organizations or maybe even functions
it doesn't mean necessarily it will suit
every person or even necessarily every
organization
it's interesting because i think there
are certain companies that have been
pushing really hard for radical
transparency for a long time for
for a decade plus um and it hasn't had
quite this moment of you know
a moment in time in which it became very
popular i think that's because it's
probably quite hard to adjust to and and
so you see companies
who really define themselves as a
company culture try to differentiate
themselves from other companies
by emphasizing radical transparency but
those companies in my view remain pretty
few and far between
in addition to the potential legal
issues surrounding employee performance
and termination transparency
a major hurdle for many companies is
making salaries public
yep it's 2021 and women are still being
paid less than men
for doing the same jobs one
step in the direction of of amending
this
this reality is to have pay
transparency in the case of paid
transparency
there's this pretty strong argument that
actually hiding
pay between your employees can hold
people back
it lets certain employees get paid more
and certain employees go underpaid for a
long time without knowing
and so there's i think a pretty strong
argument to be made
that you know pay transparency is more
fair
a 2021 washington university study
found that pay secrecy directly
contributes to the continued pay
inequality
between men and women doing the same
role
i wouldn't be surprised if certain of
the more palatable
or easy to digest changes that come with
radical transparency say maybe like
pay transparency i think that's
something that more companies
could get on board with adopting it's
less of a culture shock than
changing the way that you do all sorts
of feedback or firings or meetings or
sensitive things like that
and if that becomes more and more common
then you'll see
companies who want to distinguish
themselves thinking about
well what's next like what is something
else that we can be changing about how
we run our business that's going to make
us
better and different from our
competitors
a year of remote working has challenged
us to rethink
many of our traditional work models
and while radical transparency in its
most extreme
form may not become the norm some of its
central practices
like flexibility employee autonomy and
openness
may be on the way what the the pandemic
in the last year has done is
is kind of given a lot of people um a
lot more clarity about what matters to
them
and a lot more willingness to speak up
and also vote with their feet and i
think what we're going to see as a
result is
what might have taken kind of five to
ten years to happen i think it's going
to happen in one to two
in terms of organizational culture i
don't necessarily predict a revolution
but i predict some revolutionary
approaches
are going to start taking hold in
organizations in the next
in the next couple of years we've seen
that in a really short amount of time
things change so dramatically and for
some organizations for example it was
impossible to think like
people working from their home all day
and from one day to the other were
forced to move
to that situation and it's just so that
people keep working and things keep
moving and it's possible to do
such things
you